cette semaine du 26 avril doit permettre
donc un retour de tous les 1
physiquement les écoliers les autres à
distance les collégiens et les lycéens
ensuite il y aura donc la semaine du 3
mai c'est le retour en classe pour les
collégiens et pour les lycéens
l'enseignement sera hybride en lycée
autrement dit il y aura ce que ont déjà
connu beaucoup de lycéens c'est à dire
un enseignement en 2011 la moitié des
lycéens qui viennent et l'autre ensuite
c'est selon un système qui est organisé
à l'échelle de chaque lycée on aura donc
un peu d'enseignement à distance là
aussi pour les lycéens concernés
s'agissant des collégiens ils rentrent
au collège normalement donc pleinement
simplement pour les élèves de 4e et de
3e des quinze départements les plus
touchés par l'épidémie aussi en 2011
allez vous vacciner les enfants
là aussi c'est une question importante
mais je le dis elle n'est pas
d'actualité à l'heure à laquelle je vous
réponds à partir du 3 mai également
nous pourrons lever les contraintes de
déplacement en journée est envisagée
sous réserve de l'évolution de la
situation sanitaire
un nouveau train de réouverture autour
de la mi mai qui pourrait commencer par
les commerces certaines activités
culturelles et sportives et les
terrasses
cette liste n'est pas définitivement
fixée elle sera assortie de conditions
particulières le cas échéant je le
disais territorialisée qui évolueront au
fil des étapes
nous mettrons donc en place à compter de
samedi matin
ce sas sanitaire avec un dispositif de
quarantaine signifie qu'ils
significativement renforcée dix jours
pour tous les voyageurs en provenance
des pays où la situation sanitaire est
jugée inquiétante du fait de la cyclo
circulation de ces variants ces pays
sont à ce jour le brésil le chili
l'argentine l'afrique du sud et l'inde
et comme l'a dit monsieur le premier
ministre cette liste pourra évoluer si
cela est nécessaire
les motifs pour venir en france depuis
ces pays seront donc encore réduit pour
l'essentiel seuls les ressortissants
français et les européens ayant leur
résidence principale en france pour
entrée sur le territoire national nous
accentuerons également les mesures de
protection de nos territoires
d'outre-mer qui font face à des vagues
successives
sans lien avec ce qui se passe en
métropole c'est le cas aujourd'hui en
guyane en martinique et à la guadeloupe
où nous venons de renforcer nos mesures
et où nous allons intensifier le
programme de vaccination comme à mayotte
et à la réunion qui sont exposés aux
variants sud africain j'ai vu que
l'obésité était un facteur de risque de
formes graves
ne faut-il pas proposer la vaccination
aux personnes qui souffrent d'obésité
l'obésité est en effet un facteur de
risque de formes graves on en voit
beaucoup avec le premier ministre quand
on va dans les services de réanimation
j'ai donc saisi les comités
scientifiques pour déterminer quand et
dans quelles conditions nous pourrons
ouvrir la vaccination aux français qui
bien qu'ayant moins de 50 ans souffrent
d'obésité sévère
la réponse ne va pas tarder mais il est
probable que nous puissions là aussi
démarrer d'ici là ni même